les recettes de l'amour avec antonio la
tasmanie tu as le chef et 110 allez-vous
les noms manitas vous avez choisi
philippe etchebest qu'est le l'adjoint
du méridien de paris aux valeurs on
change alors pourquoi vous avez choisi
ce restaurant trop longtemps que j'y
vais je avoir usé ses avions jalabert
chaque fois que j'ai eu là bas pourquoi
y ait des femmes va bien sûr mais c'est
une bonne combine alors que les jets
nissan philippe etchebest vous avez
préparé quelque chose qui est typique
chez les gitans
c'est des grillades mais pas n'importe
lesquels voilà pas n'importe lesquels
donc ce sont des gambas grillées avec
une petite charlotte de légumes dans
laquelle il ya une tombe et de fenouil
et j'agrémente et ce plat avec une
petite sauce au sein ou au gingembre
justement les recettes de l'amour je ne
rappellerai pas les cas on n'a pas
besoin de gens moi j'ai l'impression
qu'on montait à lui tout seul il n'y a
pas besoin de support non un
aphrodisiaque
je suis un point c'est quoi votre photo
sia kambou tu sais c'est difficile à
dire vous pouvez vous exprimer
c'est la musique la vie mais il gagne
aussi c'est une femme dans chaque pas ou
alors la maison adam incline maison et
petit lagarde doit pas lui dire que tu
les fais les infidélités de temps en
temps je me suis pas déshabillée a très
bien
on n'a qu'à envoyer c'est pas tel fils
tel perd 5 ou 6 en bourse dans le monde
coût 6 en baisse lui verser des pensions
est ce qu'elle est
la tasse levé le noir il t'a j'aimerais
bien voulu parler des hérissons il ya
tout un mythe qui tourne autour du
risque en changeant la chapelle ou de
l'eau comme en ligue l'eau et guiglo
miglos way et vous pensez toujours du
hérisson
chaque fois que je ne trouve un jour je
te ferais manger à toi et comment sa
semence l'amour inversement il faut le
trouver il faut leur ont plu
on ne va pas préparer il faut couper la
patte à un gonfleur et son souffle dans
le gouffre car oui vous avez bien
gonflés à temps leur joie est le plus
mal et on arrive les epide l'egypte une
affaire à la blague à part c'est comment
par 3 et 5 et la peine qu'elle joue
comme un lapin comment le lapin annoncé
c'est une petite [ __ ] de mer petits
cochons de verre fils martin tu as il
avance des trucs hippisme
c'est super bon ça c'est qu'on va skier
c'est magnifique je suis la seule à
manger comme d'habitude mais je vais
partager ça avec sans dié et en tenue à
quelques instants les recettes sur le
minitel toujours laurent oui philippe
etchebest le longchamp c'est magnifique
[Applaudissements]
panini avoir gestion
je suis
très bon joueur de rugby
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]